- I just wanna take a pill
and play with my dreams.
- Lucid dreaming is where you are aware
that you're dreaming
while you're dreaming.
So then you can kinda like have some sort
of control over like,
oh I know it's a dream,
so now I'm gonna like, fly around.
- I know it once I'm in it.
I just don't know how
to make myself do it.
- If I had a lucid dream,
I would probably sleep with someone
who I know I would probably never meet.
Probably a celebrity or something.
- What is Dream Leaf?
So it's the most advanced
lucid dreaming supplement
on the planet.
- It activates neurotransmitters.
- It will enhance my dream recall.
It will promote balanced sleep.
- So you can have incredibly
vivid, memorable lucid dreams.
- Take one blue capsule
immediately before going to bed,
set your alarm to wake up.
After four hours of sleep,
take one red capsule,
and begin dreaming.
- Oh, so you have to wake up
in the night and take a pill.
How's that supposed to help your sleep?
- It's Monday night.
I'm about to take my very first blue pill.
Let's see how it goes.
Just woke up for the red pill.
If I was dreaming before,
I don't remember any of it.
- So last night was the first night.
I didn't have any different
sleep than I usually do.
- I came home like at two in the morning.
I still took my pill.
- Do it tonight.
Better results.
Blue pill.
Time for the red pill.
I did not have any cool dreams.
- [Woman] It's the middle of the night
and I woke up to take my pill.
Also, you can't see me,
because it's dark and
I wasn't going to try
and turn the light on.
Still no dreams.
- I really do hope tonight I get to fly.
Okay, day two.
And nothing happened again.
- So, this is the third
night of the pills.
And the last two nights
I have actually had like really bad sleep,
like I do in general anyway
but this was worse, somehow.
- Yo, I had a dream.
Kinda crazy.
I definitely hooked up with someone.
And that's like not a
person that I'm like,
interested in.
But I wasn't mad.
- So one of the dreams I had last night
I actually remember quite well
like probably more than normal.
- I did technically dream last night.
Where, like, some guy and
who I thought was like,
his mom, but I think later
it was like his wife,
were like at a fancy dinner
and they were arguing
but then he surprised
her with a bottle of wine
and they stopped arguing
and then I woke up.
Thanks pills.
- I had like so many insane dreams.
I remember one specifically
where I came to my friend's house
and she was just like
accidentally spilling buckets
of blood all over her carpet.
- I like having sex with unexpected people
where you're like ooo, I
never saw you in that light,
but you're alright.
I'm not a creep, I swear.
- I'm like actively dreaming now
which is all I'm asking for,
that's all I'm after here
is I wanna have cool movie dreams.
- I've definitely been
having more vivid dreams
that I remember, as far
as lucid dreaming goes,
I haven't had any of that
and I'm really sad about it.
- Dreaming three nights in a row, like,
doesn't happen for me.
Something has changed.
Only real x-factor is these pills.